welcome
welcome to this special edition of gibko
cell culture heroes
work from home my name is chelsea minnes
and i'm representing gitco and thermo
fisher scientific
and i will be your moderator today so
typically our
cell culture heroes webinars are used to
give
phds and postdoc researchers a platform
to talk about
their research on a global scale but
today i am just so proud to be joined by
six of our past gibgo cell culture
heroes
as they come together and they share
with us their experiences
with working from home and their tips
and tricks of working from home to for
staying connected to their research
their lab meets and their friends so
this presentation will be in more like
an interview
format where i can ask questions that
will enable the panel of heroes
to share their best practices of being
productive
staying connected and keeping a healthy
outlook while
this stay at home guidance so
i will be asking the heroes questions
from the audience throughout the
presentation as well
so please submit your questions by
filling in the ask a question
um box down below you can direct your
questions to a specific hero
or the whole group your questions may be
focused on working from home
but they can also talk about or be
questions aimed to hear about how the
heroes are coping with their stay at
home guidance in their personal
or social lives so i would like
to start this webinar by introducing our
speakers
and you'll see our speakers give a
little hello when i introduce them
you can also learn more about the
speakers by looking at
the tabs you'll be able to look at their
their profiles as well
so first um i would like to introduce
actually our
first our very first gibco cell culture
hero
chris dr christine wadowski
i would love to introduce thanks christy
i would love to introduce dr amit
chimote
hello
dr elizabeth dellerie hey you guys
uh dr daisy shoe
hi everyone doctor of avecma
hello everyone namaste and dr
sandra hanlon hi everyone
hi heroes i'm so happy to be here with
you today we go back
quite a bit you and i so heroes
i will direct questions to you um
specifically
however if i don't ask you a specific
question
and you would like the opportunity to
answer this question that was not
directed to you please
chime in um i would love to hear from
you
and give you the chance to touch on all
the topics that are important to you
and to our audience members i would love
to hear from you too
so i encourage you to tweet your answers
uh to the questions
live from the webinar tag at gibco
and use hashtag gitco cell culture
heroes
and here are the instructions here
your cell culture heroes and so let's
get started
okay this
first question
is for daisy and vivek hi dc hi rebecc
uh daisy we can start with you how are
you staying connected
this time with not only your research
but with people that you are used to
seeing
day to day
hi hi everyone um okay so
i are for work it's been essentially a
lot of zoom meetings and emails
um but i found it actually kind of
refreshing to
to have a departmental seminar series
conducted by
zoom because people can ask questions
and link
papers and ordinarily you'd have to like
email the person after
the the talk but now you don't you can
just like
link them immediately so that's been
really good and i feel like
also the barrier to um asking questions
sometimes it can be quite intimidating
so
when it's online people i i hear like
all these new questions coming out
from different people who don't
ordinarily ask questions so that's been
really great
um and i've had my recurrent meetings uh
weekly meetings
with my supervisor so i just had one
today actually and we have one every
tuesday at 10
um and uh we also have fortnightly
meetings with a bigger lab
group so that's been really great
because
we've maintained that kind of contact
with everyone
in terms of socially i've um maintained
contact with my friends
via like uh video chats and audio chats
texting and social media so it's been
really great to
maintain that engagement with everyone
and actually just all around the world i
feel like because it's
impacted everyone globally i feel like
we're reaching out to people
um often people i haven't been in
contact with for a while
uh so that's bringing everyone together
which is kind of nice
i agree uh how about you
uh i i completely agree with uh with
daisy actually
uh the same format is what's something
which which we are also following
but uh we have been doing this in a kind
of a unique way because
our group basically focuses more on
interdisciplinary research
so we have been working into a lot of
research associated with
wound sensors or research which is for
variable biosensors
and the good part about the group is
like we have a very diverse group
so we have graduate students and
undergraduate students phd students from
uh various disciplines like electrical
engineering we have from
uh biochemistry chemistry and the way we
are doing it is like so every every
every student has been assigned a
specific duty
uh so like students who are who are
majorly doing uh work into electrical
engineering are involved with
building up of circuits uh students who
are into
more of computer science are doing
simulation work or they're doing some
programming coding at home
uh people who are into biochemistry uh
and myself
you know we are at home uh we are
focusing more on writing grants
uh working on research papers uh so in
that aspect at least
i would say the the research component
is not that much affected
uh because uh we already have quite
substantial work which
you know everyone has taken uh taken
lead into into that area
uh on another another aspect is we are
also kind of working
uh together so we have like group
meetings uh it's quite often
uh so i uh so our pi dr bhansali uh he
has group meetings i mean we conduct
group meetings like almost
uh i guess twice a week
and i i'm like communicating with every
graduate student every twice
uh otherwise uh twice a day sometime it
happens twice a day because
it's like so everyone is having their
own small setup at their house
and you know it's like at least twice a
day we speak with each other we try to
show
circuits so we try to discuss some
problems so uh i mean
so working from home has been kind of
exciting um and
yes obviously so research is not that
much affected so
it's kind of fun that's great i like the
way that you do that
you you split the work or i guess
responsibility
so that everybody feels like they're
still contributing while at home
that's a really great idea yeah um
all right thanks vivek so our next
question
is for christine uh so christine
you are one of the few scientists within
this group at least
that can go into the lab for minimal
hours
to take care of your your cultures due
to the vital projects
that you have so how has this experience
been like for you and then also
how are you staying connected while then
out of the lab um
when you're not you know allowed within
to be with yourself
yes so we're taking some
so our laboratory members have been
deemed essential at our institute
largely due
to the um our labs work focus
largely on genetically engineered mouse
models of
cancer and that work really
takes you know on on the level of
years so uh the colony that
i'm working on i mean that took about
three and a half years and we still
haven't published it yet we hope
to submit this year so um and also
the animal welfare act means that we you
know need to care for these animals so
we have uh basically each taken
different time per day and go in during
that time so we don't really overlap
and i work about four hours
in four to five hours in the lab during
which time we all i also manage the
organoids
we have mouse tumor
derived organoids as well as um human
patient tumor derived organoids those
grow very slowly so we had to
we were not even sure we can recover
them all yet
uh from culture so
we uh i mean we're doing the best we can
but
i mean to do if a week isn't even enough
for us to
freeze down things we are freezing down
sperm of our
all of our mouth lines however that also
takes you know
two months to really confirm that uh i
don't know if
this will like will go on that long
so um yeah anyway but for the rest of
the time
uh i'm working from home i've been
analyzing data that i've been collecting
for years on organoid
um uh growth capacity so
i have hundreds of images that my
student
also is helping me mauricio i know he's
there uh also
and we've been working i know he's
logged in and um
we've been working on that as well uh
and honestly i've that's been on a lower
priority list for me
um so it's nice to bring some some of
the things
that are have been a lower priority in
the face
of the bench where i could bring them
you know higher up
because all the things need to get done
anyway
eventually so you know it
it's it's been nice that i'm an
introvert
so uh i've been really
uh pretty calm at least yeah
you've been in your in your
[Music]
we actually haven't had a lab meeting
come up
but do a little length do the
extreme length of time we take uh to do
our studies with our mice uh we have lab
meetings only like
once to twice a month so we will be
doing that
over zoom okay
um thanks christine that actually you
being in the lab and talking about
freezing down cells
that um that you can't continue
on working on right now um ties in
nicely with this
first cust or this first audience
members question
um so this question comes from audience
member
um hiya from the university of minnesota
and they want to know how are you
managing
taking care of the cells in the culture
lab during this time
so i would like to direct this question
to sandra
so sandra are there any cells in your
lab you know are there any projects that
are allowed to be ongoing
um and if not do how what are what are
your cells doing right now
yeah so luckily our lab our cells are
they're primary cells but they we have
the ability to freeze them so
our lab manager is the only one who's
been going into lab and
thank goodness for her she's been able
to hold down the fort there
and all of our cells are basically um
frozen and ready for
hopefully ready for us to when we get
back so we are really lucky in that
sense that
ourselves are they they freeze well
thanks um and thank you for that
question
um and i do want to ask this one more
question from the audience right now
this question comes from natalie
at the scripps research institute and i
will direct
this question um actually natalie would
like this question directed to both
sandra and daisy
um so daisy let's start with you and the
question
is what do you do to keep your
work from overtaking your life um your
home life
now that they are both under the same
roof so how do you balance
both research and your home life under
the same room
oh well but yeah it's a constant
struggle for me i'm not gonna lie
um it's now coming to week three of
working from home
um so it's been a lot of trial and error
for me in terms of what
works what doesn't i've tried a whole
bunch of things like i've read a lot of
different articles online um just with
lots of different methods but
i guess like in the end i think the best
thing that works for me
i've realized is not to be too rigid
with my schedule
but rather to set like um checkpoints
uh for certain tasks to be due and i
think like my weekly meetings with my
supervisor helped to
like keep me on track so um some sort of
attainable goal um
at a certain time in the week to be due
and
hold someone accountable for that and
that way
you can kind of coordinate your routine
however you like but ultimately once
that task is done then you do feel that
sense of accomplishment
um yeah it has been a
constant struggle um there's so many
distractions
everywhere um i've been like putting
limits on myself one
one somewhat effective method is to
um set times at which you can do those
things
um that are considered procrastination
uh sort of activity so um by doing that
you can try to like kind of
contain how much time goes goes into
those activities
that's a great idea i need to i need to
start
with that at the time i don't know i
have a two-year-old at home too
so it's you know for me it's trying to
balance both him and work but that's a
great idea setting
limits time limits on this thing um
all right so how about you sandra yeah i
also have a toddler at home
so i really don't have a choice to work
all day because i have to take care of
her
so that's sort of nice but at the same
time i have to be very intentional
with the time that i do work so i'm
actually doing something similar to what
daisy um
talked about i'm kind of implementing
this block scheduling
um idea and it's basically you have
certain hours of the day where you have
tasks and it's not that from nine to ten
you're going to do this or 10 to 11 it's
just like
from nine to noon these are the things
that have to get done and it kind of
gives you a little more
breathing room and a little more grace
that you have that window of time to get
those things done
and i've really tried to sort of mimic
my schedule before this whole lockdown
happen we
started self quarantining early so we've
been in lockdown for like four weeks and
it's it's been a challenge but we are
hanging in there and so really trying to
give yourself grace and some days i
definitely there's more work
involved um and other days is less
especially if there's a lot of zoom
meetings one day then i have
don't have much time to get to my
computer work so it's not that every day
is the same and i think giving
ourselves a little bit of grace in that
and being okay today was really work
heavy and that i might not have that
personal time but maybe
later in the week i can carve out more
personal time so
i think being kind to ourselves during
this time is really important
really good advice um thanks sandra
um all right let's see here so
i would like to remind the audience at
this time
to submit your questions and ask a
question box below the slides in the
video
and again i'll be asking your questions
throughout getpost questions and um
i will also try to address all audience
questions
um at the end of the presentation as
well
um also to questions that we can't get
to
in this presentation we will be
responding
via instagram or twitter um to all
questions that come in
and also email if that works better for
you
let's go to our next question this is
for elizabeth and amit
let's start with you elizabeth what is a
typical day
like for you social distancing
you may be on you elizabeth because i
can't hear ya
all right let's try i mean can you can
you uh
start with this one sure
so uh we we have been quarantining
almost for four weeks now at
the university of cincinnati so the week
approximately the week of
march 17th we were told to wind down our
experiments
and so i took one week to wind
everything down and then i started
working from home
so it's been an adjustment but i do some
small things
so basically what i do is i try to keep
my routine as normal as possible
so i wake up at the same time that i
used to wake up
which was i wake up usually between 6
and 6 30 every morning
and i kept the exact same routine so
what i would do is i wake up i take the
dog out for a walk
then i have breakfast watch the morning
news
and after that i would shower i would
shave
every day
then i would also get dressed because
sometimes what happens is just being in
sweatpants all day makes you feel lazy
you know so
i kind of get dressed every time i have
like video meetings or something
and then i come downstairs to my
temporary office which is basically my
dining table cluttered with papers
and uh then i work until five and i
usually have video meetings and uh just
like what everyone else does
we have been having regular lab meetings
every wednesday mornings
in which we discuss what we have done
with our regular work and everything
also every mondays we have one-on-one
meetings with our boss
and then for collaborative projects we
also have meetings with our
collaborators during the course of the
week
so in between that i'm lucky enough that
i'm writing a paper so i had to do data
analysis
make the figures and write the
manuscript so that keeps me fairly busy
but then what i do is i take a lunch
break around noon which is my usual time
and then i take the dog out for a walk
and then eat my lunch and
just like usual also like work what i do
is
my dinner from yesterday night i packed
for lunch this morning so i have kept
that part of the
so i don't cook anything in the morning
so i just eat whatever is there i
microwave when i eat it so that part of
the routine is the same
and i usually work until 5 30 or 6 and
then after that
i try to go for a walk or you know play
in the backyard with the dog
cook eat i love cooking so make
something to eat
then eat dinner then usually watch tv
and relax
also uh what helps me in my routine
during the week is
i set up lose goals for myself during
the week that
every monday morning i take some time to
decide like what i'm going to get
accomplished during the week
and i write that in a notebook which is
next to my desk and then
i make a itemized list what i need to do
what my meetings are
and then i check what i have
accomplished so that helps me to keep on
track
plus our lab meetings and the various
interactions we have also helps me keep
on track so
that's how i try to organize during this
and that's my routine
i do the same thing i'm i'm a big i'm
big into checklists and so
writing my to-do list down and checking
everything off throughout the day
it helps me so much and elizabeth i
think that you're back
we're this is a live event folks so we
had a bit of a technical issue but i
think that
i think you're back now elizabeth yeah i
missed the question though
so if you wouldn't mind repeating that
no problem
so the question is what is a typical day
like for you
while social distancing and that is a
great question i'm actually
i have asthma so i'm actually a high
risk individual so i've been
taking social distancing very seriously
and i've been quarantining
uh myself and working from home for the
last four weeks
um it's been rough i know christine
mentioned she's an introvert but i
am so exceptionally extroverted it's
insane sometimes and i miss
people and i miss interaction so it was
a little rough in the beginning and like
there was that first week when like it
was cool at first i was like great i can
like
sleep in a little bit work from home
it's going to be awesome and then it
kind of got like
a little depressing and you know i was
sad and i miss people which is totally
normal like it's okay
you know this has never happened before
in modern times like it's okay
to be a little off while you're
adjusting to everything you know i got
back into the swing of things i had to
set a routine for myself
which is like getting up and getting
ready as if
i'm going to work so that means getting
up doing what i would normally do so you
know putting makeup on
getting dressed in work clothes um you
know eating my protein bar for breakfast
i know for like for a little bit i was
actually hopping in my car and just
driving around the block
and then like coming back inside to
simulate that i was like driving to work
to keep my routine
and then i said you know the time points
like answer emails in the morning
you know when i'm you know not really
awake and still kind of getting
everything together
and then um my dogs are fighting in the
background
and then that's that's been the biggest
distraction working from home is my
two adorable dogs who want my attention
all the time
um but then it's like you know work on
i'm working on um some review articles
right now as well as like editing review
articles for some of my co-workers
um so doing that kind of thing in the
afternoon and then
you know taking my dogs for a walk
before dinner and then to socialize i'm
either spending time with my husband and
doing like
netflix and like binging a show or uh
the reason thing we've been doing is the
zoom happy hour
uh where all my friends you know we all
get our favorite drink we
log in and we uh socialize over
webcams so uh i get my little
extroverted fix
uh i'm keeping that kind of like normal
schedule
as best i can while working from home
has been like super great for me
yeah yeah let's see the dog
where's wishbone
[Music]
so this is thor he was kind of playing
earlier
um every once in a while that was
impossible with the screen i had to hide
a squeaky in my desk because then he'd
be really annoying in the background
and wishbone is anti-social right now
but uh yeah if you hear them they're
in the background playing awesome thanks
elizabeth all right
so i want to move to questions from the
audience now because we are getting
so many um here is a question
from andrew and um let's direct this one
to you because i haven't gotten a chance
to hear from you
yet so um andrew's i
am starting on my phd
since out of the lab i'm looking for
ways to keep myself
engaged what ideas can you
give early phd students or graduate
students
um to do at home during this time
wow that's a pretty serious question but
so so to to answer it like
so let's let's break it down like if we
see like undergrads undergrad students
uh what i would suggest is
there are plenty of online resources
obviously most of the undergrads right
now busy with their finals or you know
they're busy with some other things
but after your final exams you know uh
you have plenty of online resources
uh students can log into coursera they
can log into edx
uh harvard online programs uh also
thermofisher also has online resource
center learning center where they can
log in
and believe me like everything is free
you just have to log in
and select whichever subject you want
and then you can start off the course
and obviously there are certifications
so if if students are interested in
going ahead for any certification you
can
you can have a certification in that
particular area uh so that is something
which i would recommend for undergrads
like you know
you have plenty of time right now you
can invest the time into
maybe online learning learning a
particular subject which you like which
would enhance your career
second thing is if you're new into your
phd course
you can go for learning scientific
writing
like that is a major challenge which a
lot of undergrads grads and
early pg students face like in one of
the surveys which we conducted we
uh it came up it came up that a lot of
students face a problem
writing the introduction so my mentor
always tells me like you know writing a
research paper is something like
you are a director of a movie and um
you know you have to direct it like and
all the components should be there like
you know there should be an actor there
should be
some drama there should be some kind of
you know everything
so so research paper writing is also
very important skill
so you know students can engage into
research writing
another component is graphical
representations so there are plenty of
software's
bio render is one software where you
know
students can learn how to use biorender
how to use graphical
representations uh graphpad prism is
another software where
you can really make good graphs uh good
graphical
abstracts uh graphical uh you know
statistical
tools uh you can learn those uh also
um um if if any of the if any of you are
interested in like
uh something like learning intellectual
property because we as researchers we
always
get involved with the lab routine and
getting getting to know about
intellectual property rights and how
how you could file patents how you can
protect your research how you can
translate your research from a lab to an
industry then
a wipo which is a world intellectual
property right organization
so they have these free training
workshop and modules on their website
you can just
go ahead and you know select any of
those training workshops
uh this this would give give you more of
a more of
an in-depth knowledge that how do you
translate your lab research to an
industrial research how do you
how do you have that pathway going
towards commercializing your research or
something
second thing is you can also speak with
your mentor if you can write a review
article during this time because
everyone is at home
so it would be more like uh i guess the
review article if you write right now
it will eventually become your first
introduction chapter of a thesis
so writing review article is one thing
and lastly
uh for some senior phd students
[Music]
you can train yourself on writing
research grants so
maybe go on nsf.gov or nih.gov
or dod websites where you have these
templates of research grants
um so how do you write research grant
how do you prepare budgets how do you
um how do you what is the particular
format um so you know all those all
those things you can do it
in this phase and i personally believe
like you know
uh this is this is a really good time
for everyone since they are at home
and uh you have plenty of time with you
uh to think and you know to plan your
work in such a way that you know you
learn something different
and uh i mean this is something which is
which is to me but i
i would i would definitely like to
suggest everyone that you know
science is something like it cannot be
divided in subjects like
i i i heard a lot of time like people
are like oh i'm a molecular biologist so
i need not worry about
any other discipline or i am an electro
electrical engineer i need not worry
about biochemistry but ultimately you
know
everything is like everything everything
is connected to science and
um you know if you have knowledge of
every every particular discipline
it gives it elevates you like you have a
very different horizon like to
think on a research topic or to discuss
so there are several activities
which uh you know um students can engage
themselves
the most easiest one i would suggest is
go online
there are plenty of resources and do a
small certification course so
that's it
thanks so much yeah that was not
comprehensive and wonderful thank you so
much um
i'd also like to let everybody know
online that we have a lot of great
resources on thermofisher.com um
specifically
um thermofisher.com connect to science
you'll find a lot of webinars and app
notes and every a lot of resources
during this time um also for free so
take a look
at one more thing uh
so one more thing is like uh
some of the students can also enroll
into some scientific uh
uh membership like acs or rsc
uh because uh if you're a member of
those communities
uh you know once you're a member you get
to know a lot about
internship opportunities travel grants
uh you get to collaborate with different
uh students
uh from their community so that is
something which you can do
later not now but at least if you can if
students can think of enrolling
themselves
into scientific comment uh memberships
yeah oh that's a great idea
um okay so let's move to our next
question then
um this question is for christine and
amit so christine will start with you
what advice can you give to your peers
who are working from home and they are
having a hard time finding a rhythm
oh okay so um i feel as though
a meat has really uh lay that
like gave in a really good um
summary one thing i would say is that
and i've done this before and
i happen to be uh have been privileged
enough
i live in buffalo new york and the rent
is actually pretty
cheap here so we do have an extra
bedroom which is where i'm in now
and um so this space
ever since i moved in here uh which is
six years ago now um it
is for work only so
grant writing i do sometimes
stay home or i choose to stay home
to write something if i have some kind
of grant or
a paper or something that i i want to
write so i find having a separate space
but of course not everyone is has all
that space
so i would just choose two different
chairs and be like
i'm sitting this is my chair at my
dining room
that i'm eating my dinner and relaxing
this is the chair
my work chair you know they could be the
same chair
but just like sit in a different area i
find that
because um we're used to having the
physical
transition of leaving the house
coming back in the house and um
you know psychologists have known for a
long time when you go in and
you're struggling with anxiety you go in
see you talk therapist that's one of the
things
they ask often about when you're
struggling with anxiety
is about transitions and
i've i actively think about that
even transitioning to sleep time like
different things like that
i kind of need a defined
transition um so that's one of the
good healthy way to do that so
thanks christine and amy i know that you
did already touch on this a little bit
earlier
is there anything else that you wanted
to add about um
how you're working to find a rhythm
you know in keeping up with your work
well let me say something uh just a
little bit different so
what i want to say is like you know you
get in the rhythm because
many times we have goals that we have
set up and this is something we want to
achieve but
it's not 100 all the time you know
i know several of us are having trouble
finding a rhythm or trying to achieve
their goals as to
what they want to do you know but what i
want to tell them is that you know
don't be too hard on yourself right now
we are in difficult times and
all of us are pretty much adjusting to a
new reality of
life so i would like to tell people that
it's okay to be anxious
but at the same time what i would say is
that like what i
said earlier is that set some kind of an
achievable goal for yourself
and even when you achieve those small
victories it will make you feel good
so don't worry about not feeling
unproductive or you know
if i don't get this done if i don't
write that paper in like two weeks what
will my boss think or what will people
think
we are all in this together and people
will definitely understand
also what i would like to tell people is
in spite of the hectic schedule do take
some time out
for some self-care and to maintain your
own sanity
connect with your friends connect with
your co-workers if you're having any
trouble communicate honestly with your
supervisor
or your boss and tell them how you're
feeling
connect with your friends using facetime
or zoom
or any kind of web chat call the phone
talk to your family
also check in on your neighbors and just
take care of yourselves and be kind to
one another
that's how we will all get through this
so that's all i want to say about that
thanks so much amy um so i actually have
a question
it's kind of similar to one that we have
um already asked but i did want to ask
this one specifically because it's
coming from
um our instagram account actually uh
and this one is for sandra and it's from
amazon
or at sciencephdcreative um
and sorry i'm gonna read this from my
phone since it's coming in from
instagram and it says thanks so much for
organizing this webinar
you're welcome i'm all um and and i'm
asked this one to sandra
because it says in in case of
zoom lab meetings i'm curious to know
any advice or tips of staying productive
and less distracted um so sandra you can
take that question any way you like um
whether it's zoom lab meetings or or
you know just working from home in
general what
are you doing um or what advice tips can
you give
for staying productive and less
distracted
thanks so much yeah for me staying less
distracted is huge
because like i said i have a little
two-year-old distraction running around
constantly meeting my attention but
i really uh try to set
goals and i know a lot of us have
mentioned this but really try to set
goals and
attainable goals i think is huge too
even if it's literally
make your bed you know check those small
that just like feeling of checking that
box will will give you the momentum
that you have and i'm a by nature i'm
very
list oriented and i'm very schedule
oriented even before this whole lockdown
so and that might not work for everyone
right that might be someone's like worst
nightmare to have that so i think the
most important tip is to really
do a self-reflection and see what works
for you
making lists and kind of planning out my
days in those blocks has been pretty
effective to maintain the productivity
and having clear goals for myself
has been helpful and giving myself
grace that i might not achieve all those
things that day and that's okay i'll
pick up the next day and continue them
so uh really doing some self-reflection
and
seeing what works for you what works
before this whole lockdown how can you
really
make that um transition and how can you
implement that to your current situation
and giving yourself um a little bit of
flexibility that
like many of us said this is
unprecedented we have unprecedented
challenges and every day is different so
really day by day
and trying to have clear goals i think
is going to be very helpful
i'm trying to stay productive awesome
thank you um so
here's a here's a more fun question i
think
or one that is a little bit more
refreshing looking towards when this is
all over
um coming from our audience uh and they
did not leave a name so i'm just going
to read the question here and
address it to elizabeth and vivec it's
from oh it is it's from kathy from asu
sorry kathy
so what do you look forward to doing
when you're free from quarantine oh that
sounds wonderful
elizabeth we can start with you i've
already made a list
like i'm like i have something to look
forward to and focus on
um that's going to be great for what
it's all you know it helps me get
through
knowing that i have things to look
forward to at the end um i've already
started designing
experiments i'm going to do in lab when
i get back so it's like having that
design set up like even where i'm going
to put my beakers and like
pipets and all that i have that all laid
out because i'm ready to go when lab
opens back up again
uh in personal life though i absolutely
miss
my gym like crazy i love to lift heavy
um so uh i am uh
really looking forward to going to the
gym because you know working out at home
and going for a run and using like
exercise bands and free weights isn't
the same as like dead lifting your body
weight
so i really miss the gym that's the
other one and then the third one
i missed my favorite bar slash
restaurant in new orleans
um and they closed down obviously for
you know employee safety
but when this is all over i'm gonna go
get a burger and a bloody mary with a
bunch of my friends at my favorite you
know bar
in new orleans so we've already like set
all that up and i'm those are the three
things i'm like super looking forward to
so exciting i know i i know there's a
lot of
scientists cell culture scientists
especially missing they're
missing their cell babies right now um
and so i can only imagine
what that's like i'm how about you vivek
so i live in miami and uh you know i'm
missing out on a lot of things
because uh you know like this this city
has a
has a different vibe altogether um but
um i'm just waiting like you know once
this thing just gets over i'm just gonna
go to the lab
uh my cells are waiting for me uh i had
to cry preserve them you know i hadn't
had any option although you know
uh i all i wanted to work but uh but
yeah i mean they're waiting for me and
then we have some experiments
uh i mean so so this is the thing like
early early in
early in jan i thought that okay 2020 is
going to be the best year for me
because all my experiments are lined up
and you know i'm gonna really gonna
really gonna make good get get really
good publications but then this thing
happened and then
uh my undergrads are working with me
they keep on teasing me like okay so
we're not going to the lab so you know
it's so nice and
stuff like that but but i'm actually i'm
actually waiting that once everything
just gets over i'll be just going to the
lab and starting back work
so i'm just waiting for that yeah i know
and
both of your questions tie into one of
our audience members questions
um so i don't need to ask this but greg
from iris bio he asks pretty much the
same thing what
what experiments are you planning as
soon as you get back in the lab or are
you thinking about experiments so
um i know that that most of you are
probably just counting down
to to get back into the lab so um thanks
so much for that question greg
um okay so let's
move to our next question and also i
just
want to remind the audience to submit
questions write them in the ask a
question box below
although i think that most of you are
finding them because we're just seeing
so many questions come in
and i promise that we will address
everybody if not in this webinar
than after the webinar um so my next
question is for daisy
and elizabeth daisy will start with you
and it's another refreshing question
what is something positive
to come from working from home
for me the biggest positive thing is uh
to really have
this precious time to like sit down and
read and write which is something that
i think it's really hard to carve out
that time
generally when you're doing experiments
because your mind's in experiment mode
and you almost have this guilt if you're
not at the bench
generating new data so um yeah it's been
it's been really great for me to
uh finally hone in on my review article
and try to
dive into the literature uh the other
thing is that i started my postdoc
uh in january last year so i've
collected
a good year and a bits worth of data
that
i am now trying to fix into the bigger
picture of
my field um and just to find those
missing pieces
uh so for me it's been like
taking a really good look at the data
that i have so far
um seeing if i can actually turn it into
a manuscript
maybe that would be great um but yeah
just and then just trying to find those
missing pieces
uh for when i do go back to lab i can
immediately uh get started on filling
those gaps um
so yeah it's actually been that that's
that's one really big positive thing to
come of this
because i think i've never had to slow
down this much in my life
um so it's really taught me a lot about
that and patience as well
thank you so much daisy um and elizabeth
something positive for you
to come from working from home well i
know something my boss is going to love
i i like to move around a lot and be
really active so lab work is one of my
favorite things and reading journal
articles you know i do it
recommend at least one journal article a
day but like people are always
publishing
tons of new papers are coming out every
day it's hard to stay up on top of
things and so
you know working from home has forced me
to like actually have to sit down and
like get caught up on all of the
literature
you know i got put to the side because i
was doing experiments in the lab all the
time
and then personally another positive
that came out of it
in january and february we were doing a
lot of cell staining
and the protocol we had set up was about
10 hours and so i'd just
knock it all out and be at work like all
day i'd get home it was dark
it was time to eat and like go to bed
and stuff and so being able to be home i
can you know
walk my dogs during the daytime which
they absolutely love
you know i can have dinner with my
husband and spend time with him so like
i've appreciated the fact that it's
forced me to slow down
and spend quality time with like my dogs
and my husband so i really appreciate
that too
awesome thanks and thanks i just want to
give everyone shout outs who's tagging
us on social right now
um so science phd creative again
uh fosso pasta thanks so much guys
um and then also i would love to hear
from the audience
um on that last question so what is
something
positive to come from working from home
tweet us your answers at gibco let us
know something positive that you've
experienced while working from home
um we're all looking for some light
during this time so
um i would love to hear from you okay
so we have a more personal social
question coming from um
sapna at ucla and we will direct this
question into christine
um so christine have you taken any
hobbies
since social distancing measures have
been put in place
yes okay so i'm really excited about
this
i so prior to this so my shift the time
for me to work is like 10 a.m
[Music]
to three or four and i am a morning
person
so i was never really home from seven to
ten
and i noticed that there were tons of
birds
perching on my porch i live in an upper
i live in a house
but at the upper part and we have a
porch and so
i saw all these birds perching um
right now it's only just starting to get
a little warm like it's not even warm
it's like 40 degrees
let's be honest it definitely snowed
like a few days ago it's buffalo but the
birds
come now this time so i had
i bought a bird feeder now and
every morning like i get up i get up
in the morning time when i usually would
get up and now i have my
my tea or coffee in front of the window
and i watched the birds and now i'm
learning all about the different birds
around
and i'm also like inter i'm really
interested
possibly in collecting data about it but
maybe
that's a scientist and me like buy the
webcam i could count as many birds
come to it the length of time they purge
all this kind of stuff
i'm really starting to get interested in
this and i wasn't really interested
i never even noticed the bird much
before
so so that's cool
i love that um
okay wow so so this is
my last question and then we're going to
be moving to all
audience member questions in the last 10
minutes here
um and i would like to direct this
question to sandra and amit
sandra what are some things that
audience members can be doing
can be doing at home during quarantine
sorry
yeah so i think some of the most
useful things that i've tried to
accomplish during this time is really
go back and look up the data that i have
to really do an analysis of all the data
that i've collected that's not
been published and try to see if i can
write
up um a manuscript or try to
you know make um sense of that data and
see if
anything that really fits into a nice
story and start to
write that paper and i've also started
to
outline manuscripts for projects that
aren't processed
and these um just you know drafting the
introduction or drafting figures that i
already have completed
um drafting results and materials like
materials and methods section stuff that
we
usually just you know do at the end so
once that
once i get back to the lab then i'll
really have um
you know that i
might you're you should be thinking like
you should always be doing that but
unfortunately
i don't so it's really um those are like
the couple things that
are really been helpful and also um i
have an
a student that works with me and she's
been really helpful in
helping me spruce up any presentations
that i might have coming up
and since now most of them are in zoom
she's been really great at adding more
animation
and more um changing it a little bit
different since it's
virtually rather than in person so
really sprucing up upcoming
presentations
improving the images using biorender we
recently started using that has been
great on improving
grant figures things like that so really
writing up complete or almost complete
papers
outlining manuscript for projects that
are in process and sprucing up
presentations or
some of the the key things that i think
are pretty helpful
but yeah that's a great great idea of
the presentations i forgot about them
um and and how about you and me is there
anything else that you would like to add
there
so basically uh sandra and vivek have
already touched on a lot of things
so what i would what i have been doing
and working on my paper but at the same
time i am also attending a lot of
webinars
online to learn a lot and i have also
recently
jumped on the bio-render bandwagon and
biorender has weekly webinars that they
do on how to make good figures for
grants how to organize a powerpoint so
those have been very useful and i'm
doing some schemes from the paper using
biorender so
it has been very useful also for this
paper i have some data using nanostring
so i'm trying to navigate
how to utilize the pathway analysis and
everything for nanostring
i had never done single cell like
rna-seq kind of analysis before so
it's all new for me so i'm learning that
and i'm educating myself on that
so apart from doing my day job which i
think is doing my paper
i'm utilizing this time to also attend a
lot of webinars and learn
newer things which i wouldn't have time
usually in working
the usual 12 hour days in the lab you
know so i can learn
a lot new things and maybe people's you
know add to my skill set
also another tip what i had read
somewhere online which i would like to
share with the audience
i personally haven't done it because
it's very intimidating for me
but a lot of people are saying that this
is a very very good opportunity to learn
r
the r package for making graphics and
learn programming in r because
uh it's going to be very useful in the
future you know for that so
i would encourage people to into it
so yeah thank you so much
amit um and so everyone that concludes
gibco's questions but we have
so many so many questions that i don't
think we will get to everybody but i'm
gonna try
hard in this last five minutes or so to
um address some questions from the
audience
um and so i would like to start
things off with a fun one that just
keeps this question has been staring at
me
since since i've seen it come in and so
i'm going to ask it
to elizabeth um what
shows are you binge watching right now
have you seen
tiger king
oh that's a great question um
binge watching i'm trying to stay on the
positive happy shows just like
you know humor is great laughter is one
of the best medicines um
so i've been watching like binging
brooklyn nine nine
and like super story like those short
30-minute comedy so i get that little
like boost and pick me up and yes
eventually i gave in and watched tiger
king because i was really curious
but don't worry my dog also enjoyed it
too
they were fascinated by the tigers and
the large animals on the screen and they
were constantly running up to like
sit there and just like stare at it so i
think they got more enjoyment out of it
than i did
but uh yeah no short comedies are my
thing
yeah that that was a great question
thank you guys
um you want to add in um amit mentioned
watching uh
webinars and things like that there's a
really good one out from greater good
science uh and i can post the link i
think on twitter later but it's a free
webinar on like maintaining happiness
during
the kobit 19 crisis and so they have
like little activities and homework
assignments um
you know just to help you stay happy and
staying during this time and i think
it's a very great
webinars i'm gonna you know promote that
one a little bit
thank you so much and actually that was
that was a question that came in from
the audience
and i can't find who asked this question
now but
um it was that i hit a question from the
audience so thank you so much for
for saying that um elizabeth and i also
just want to say
with this topic of webinars um
of course we have all of our gibco cell
culture
webinars um at thermofisher.com
cell culture heroes you can see all of
these wonderful
um speakers webinars about their
research
but also i think about 15 other webinars
that you can watch on demand on
thermofish.com for free
um covering so many different topics
um 3d cell culture you know
immunotherapies can't
whatever it is so um take a look at
getcostalculturehero's webpage as well
um obviously if you missed lab the
thermo fisher has that virtual lab you
can
do right yeah yeah absolutely and i'll
give everybody links to that after
after the webinar too um so this next
question actually we're going to make
this our last question
because sadly we have to end soon um but
this next question comes from
julia from cal state for sandra
um so you said that you have a
two-year-old at home
i do too how have you been balancing the
guilt
of either paying attention to your work
or your toddler how or have you found
success in making sure that they have
both been getting the appropriate
attention
great question so short answer
no i have not if you have the speaker
please let me know but uh
so like i said my day mostly revolves
around her schedule
so i tend to do most of my zoom meetings
or i try to
um schedule most of my zoom meetings and
things like that during her nap time
she's still napping for about two two
and a half hours so it gives me a little
bit of time to
jam those meetings in and then most of
my focus work
um will either happen after she goes to
bed at night
or my husband is also working from home
so we kind of you know
play tag team constantly and in an ideal
world you know be the best
like pinterest creative mom and the most
productive postdoc but that's just not
that's not my reality and um i try to
set her up
if i have um you know emails or computer
work i try to center up with an activity
that usually gives me about five minutes
at a time and
i can you know do what i need to do in
those um
couple minutes and then just we're on to
a next activity i'm really looking
forward to
where i live it's not it's still winter
basically
so i'm looking forward to the nice
weather where i can just take her
outside and maybe bring my computer
along but yeah
i have not found the magic and some days
i feel like i'm crushing it at mom life
and some days i feel like i'm crushing
it at postdoc life
and you know some days i feel like both
some days i feel like
not either of them but um it's a good
it's a bi-day-by-day basis
so yeah thank you i think that there's
probably
a lot of us that can relate whether it
be um kids at home
or working with your new co-worker who
is your roommate or
family who are also working from home
and this is a super weird time
for everybody and um i think that we're
all just taking it one day
at a time one step at a time one breath
at a time
so thank you for that sanja um so that
actually concludes our gibco cell
culture heroes
work from home edition uh we encourage
all of our audience members to continue
submitting questions
if you haven't already on twitter by
tweeting at gibco and using
um our hashtag hashtag gibco subculture
heroes
um you can also tag us on in your
instagram stories at getcocellculture
um again we have so many questions that
we did not have the chance to uh
address today but um i
i we will we will get to everybody
through email twitter however it is that
you reached out to us
um so also again i would like you to
check out our glucose cell culture
heroes
webpage again i mentioned this in the
webinar um but you can check out
you can watch these speakers webinars on
their research as well as their other
heroes research
and that's a link is right there that
you can click and finally
we mentioned a lot of resources
available to you
in this time when you're looking for um
education and
and articles and things like that so um
to help your research momentum
while out of the lab thermo official
scientific has compiled a very rich
collection of webinars and
e-learning courses app notes videos
articles
and more which can be found at
thermofisher.com
connect to science so i encourage you to
check that out
thank you all so much for joining i hope
that you stay
safe and we hope to see you back in the
lab very soon
thank you